antoine werner céline durchon voilà la
chapelle daumail et où se trouvait la
crèche historique de châteauneuf pendant
cent ans à la place désormais depuis
plusieurs années une crèche de
substitution l'original fierté du
village il y avait été installée à la
fin du 19e siècle avant de disparaître
dans les années 90 elle était là pendant
100 ans elle a été exposée à la
vénération à la prière et paroissiales
châteauneuf pendant 100 ans elle est
partie mais elle va revenir sa place est
ici bien sûr dans ce combat pour
récupérer la crèche me curé peut compter
sur le maire se dit grand jeu vous
répéter voilà donc on vient vous voir
pour avoir votre aide
mais aussi sur les commerçants pour
rallier tous les habitants c'est un
combat global c'est un combat c'est pas
le maire et le curé c'est un ensemble
c'est la population entière qui doit
être derrière nous soutenir notre
démarche de manière à ce qu'on récupère
notre bien notre patrimoine qui est issu
de la basilique mais qui est aussi de
notre patrimoine communal un patrimoine
appartenant donc à châteauneuf
mais aujourd'hui bien loin du cher 25
ans après sa disparition la crèche
refait surface sur le bon coin
elle se trouve à nîmes chez un
particulier qui a décidé de la mettre en
vente
et pourtant elle est sur le bon coin
[Musique]
pas encore de terrain d'entente entre le
curé la propriétaire de la crèche
mais le prêt très déterminés ils
menacent même d'entamer une procédure
auprès du tribunal administratif